life is getting more expensive
all around the world people are watching
as prices get pumped up by forces beyond
their control
i'm talking about
inflation right now countries and even
entire continents are seeing costs
increase for everything from food to
clothing to fuel going to the grocery
store food is way more expensive than it
was even a year ago so a lot of people
are having trouble making ends meet in
this video we'll explore why first thing
ceos will do is pass the prices on to
consumers we'll also look at what's
being done to tackle inflation and
whether those measures are working or
simply making things worse it's cut
policy rates aggressively this year and
inflation as a result of a spiraled out
of control welcome to business beyond
[Music]
let's begin in the united states where
inflation is at a 40-year high a survey
by the u.s census bureau suggests in the
richest country in the world people are
struggling to be able to afford what
they need roughly a quarter of the
people who
make less than the poverty line have
said
yes i'm hungry and i don't have enough
food because i can't afford it
and then people who are you know even
above the poverty line but kind of like
lower middle class
um you know and even middle middle class
so people making up to fifty thousand
dollars a year
you know at least eleven percent of
those people are saying yes i'm hungry
and the reason why is because
i can't afford to buy food
so how did the united states get here
this may sound counterintuitive but
actually the pandemic made americans on
average richer
the u.s government sent out thousands of
dollars in stimulus checks people who
lost their jobs received months of
generous unemployment benefits and
soaring stock prices boosted the wealth
of the wealthiest as a result
savings soared
and starting in early 2021 americans
began to spend that money on things like
tech and clothes and going to reopened
restaurants and bars
but high demand has collided with
snarled up supply chains
at least in the u.s a lot of goods are
imported
from where
from asia china in particular
and china and many other asian economies
have a zero tolerance policy for kobit
19
so whenever there's an outbreak
factories are shut down
workers are not allowed to move around
people can't engage in activities
and so that affects the supply chain so
you have strong demand for these goods
imported goods
insufficient supply of those goods
and so that leads to higher inflation
and the costs of doing business keep
getting higher too
apart from expensive raw materials
businesses are also struggling with
staff shortages finding people
especially for in-person work in the
retail or hospitality industries has
become difficult for various reasons
including increased illness risk or
difficulty finding child care for
children who can't go into school
businesses are raising wages
to attract workers
and for some businesses
they can absorb that into their profit
margins or they might cut costs
somewhere else to accommodate for the
wages in the us the first thing ceos
will do is pass the prices on to
consumers contributing to inflation the
u.s federal reserve has indicated it
could increase interest rates three
times during 2022. now higher rates make
borrowing more expensive
and saving more appealing it encourages
people to put their money away rather
than spend it that would suppress demand
and prevent prices from getting ever
higher heading off a potential wage
price spiral if people start going to
their bosses and saying well you know
everything costs more
i need a raise
then
then it begins so the boss says okay
i'll give you a raise
but then if everybody gets a raise and
businesses companies will say well now i
can charge more it just becomes this
vicious cycle
across the atlantic in the countries
that use the euro the risks of inflation
are also being assessed
here in europe the surge in inflation
has been particularly surprising because
over the past decade policymakers have
been battling the precise opposite
problem
stubbornly low inflation europe was an
example of this but actually this is a
developed economy issue the concern was
sort of the japanification of the entire
developed world
and what's really behind that is an
excess of savings so a savings glut but
saving money is good right
well
not always over the past two decades
people in developed countries have been
saving a lot of money too much actually
it means they haven't been spending or
investing as much as they could be and
that in turn
can constrain economic growth and
inflation
in the first months of the pandemic
fears over low inflation deepened
inflation actually turned negative in
the euro zone as people stayed home and
businesses shut reducing demand and
prices for goods and commodities
as in the us that changed in 2021 in
part thanks to a vaccine rollout that
allowed businesses and consumers to
start spending again driving demand and
prices back up but that's just part of
the story it leaves out the single most
important driver of inflation here
inflation has been driven much more by
energy costs in europe and the causes
for higher energy costs are multiple
they range from weather patterns so the
wind didn't blow as much off the shores
of germany as they had in the past
a lack of investment in infrastructure
particularly renewable energy
low
low inventories for oil and gas already
and then of course geopolitical strains
with russia amassing troops and weapons
along the border with ukraine that has
caused the big change in pricing for
energy energy bills for households in
western europe are expected to soar this
year by as much as 54
that's left policymakers at the european
central bank in frankfurt in a tricky
spot their only job is to control
inflation and inflation has been running
significantly above their two percent
target there's really nothing that the
ecb can do about energy costs
and so i do think that
given that the fiscal stimulus in europe
was much
smaller than in the us you're not facing
the kind of demand-driven inflation in
europe that you are in the u.s and so
there's very little that the ecb has in
its toolbox to address it
ecb president christine lagarde has been
crystal clear the central bank believes
that this surge in inflation will pass
and soon the ecb expects inflation to
fall sharply this year as the heat's
taken out of the energy market this is
just a temporary
blip in terms of higher inflation
because we still have a glut of savings
there are a number of kind of big
structural drivers of high
savings high national savings across the
developed world and they include things
like demographics which haven't changed
at all if anything they've just been
made worse because of the pandemic so i
think that
in a year or two this blood of savings
should reassert itself
leaving the eurozone now and on to its
eastern neighbour turkey where the
inflation story is largely one of
self-inflicted pain
turkey is experiencing one of the
world's most brutal inflation surges but
unlike much of the rest of the world it
didn't start with supply chain shortages
soaring commodities prices or
skyrocketing demand
many economists say the blame lies
squarely at the feet of turkey's
president recep tayyip erdogan adam
doesn't believe in the the basics of
monetary policy the basics of
of of
market economics which is the higher
interest rates
uh counter inflation he doesn't believe
that he argues that high interest rates
cause inflation
is
[Music]
the central bank of turkey has not been
able to run
orthodox policy it's cut policy rates
aggressively this year or over the last
year on direction from edwan
inflate and inflation as a result of a
spiraled out of control turkey's
government statistics agency puts
inflation at an already breathtaking 36
percent however researchers analyzing
thousands of prices within turkey say
inflation is more like 83
the feeling of the people
are totally different from the
government pressure inflation figures
on the street on the daily life
[Music]
but no matter how high inflation gets
erdogan continues to insist that
interest rates are kept low and he's
shown he's willing to sack any central
banker who disagrees with him
this unconventional approach has had a
number of knock-on effects for the
turkish economy among them it's put off
foreign businesses and investors 2010-11
everyone wanted to get into turkey
university had high growth great
demographics good banks good corporates
what's changed there is an orthodox
policy which means top go cycles makes
it very difficult to plan
uh you know if you don't know what it
what inflation is going to be and where
the exchange rate is going to be how can
any business
plan investments and
broader activity
but worse it's led to a sharp
deterioration in the lives of most turks
in the capital istanbul people wait in
long lines for subsidized bread
means erdogan's controversial economic
approach could end up costing him his
presidency
he's up for re-election in 2023
and opinion polls show support for him
eroding the last decade of akp rule uh
under erdogan unchained
has been one of um
you know living standards
uh falling
of inequality rising ultimately that
will will will make it very difficult
for everyone to be re-elected
re-election or no re-election enough
damage has already been done and experts
say it could only get worse if turkey
continues on its current path i believe
that the turkish economy will be
experiencing the sudden stop
in two or three years inflation
will be reaching to the three
digit level the profit will be lower
than the average cost of the production
then
for any firm
there will be no single reason to open
the door and make the production
in the short run and in the middle
our next stop shows how easily
frustration over inflation can boil over
into political crisis
kazakhstan has long been seen as an
example of a remarkably stable
post-soviet state one with vast oil and
gas reserves plenty of foreign
investment and a regime that's been in
place since the fall of the soviet union
30 years ago
that changed in january as protests
rocked the central asian country
what began as a demonstration over a
government decision to remove price
controls on a key fuel source turned
into a wider backlash of a rising
inflation and inequality the
demonstrations hit a raw nervous seam of
unhappiness in kazakhstan that
elites in the country had had milked
those
those massive
earnings from from raw materials and
kept most of them themselves and hadn't
actually distributed very much down to
the lower level so you know this was
also uh this is about inequality and uh
social injustice and falling living
standards so something
so two two important points i think but
inflation certainly was a spark and that
leaves kazakhstan facing twin economic
and political crises and while the
protests have since been quelled neither
crisis shows any signs of being close to
being resolved in the end president
takayev seems to have only been able to
restore order with the backstop of
russian troops it was president putin
essentially saying takayef is my man i'm
willing to back him and the challenge i
think there is um what that means for
kazakh sovereignty um
putin
the there will be a fee to be paid or a
price to be paid for that
more than 200 people died in january's
protests in kazakhstan according to the
authorities there and 8 000 people were
detained
kazakhstan should serve as a cautionary
tale to the rest of the developing world
in the poorest countries inflation is
threatening people's abilities to feed
themselves to keep a roof over their
heads or to put fuel in their cars to
get to work for politicians that's
something that's becoming impossible to
ignore higher inflation ultimately means
lower growth
but it also means um the poor suffered
disproportionately
many of these countries already have
weak social and political systems
they're vulnerable they're very
vulnerable
unless they quickly get inflation under
control
inflation affects everyone we all need
food clothes and a way to keep warm
that's why policymakers have a vital job
in keeping it under control and
protecting the poorest among us
wherever we are in the world
and that's it from this edition of
business beyond if you've enjoyed it do
hit like and subscribe and while you're
here why not check out one of our other
videos we recently did one about the
global energy crisis that's well worth
orange until next time
take
[Music]
you